THE DUCKS CLEAR IT THE OTHER
WANT TO MAKE SURE YOU ON THE
WINNING END ANY TIME YOU GO
HEAD-TO-HEAD.
I
THERE IS,
DRYSDALE , VERY ACTIVE.
THEY ARE NOT AFRAID TO JUMP
INTO THE PLAY.
>> Pat:
AND A BEAUTIFUL PAD SAVETHE
OFFENSIVE ZONE.
>> Pat: THERE IS ZEGRAS
SHIPPING IT OVER TO , 35.
BILL MURRAY WITH THE SAVE AND
STILLMAN.
FINALLY STILLMAN CHECKED HIS
MAN, WON THE PUCK, THEN FOR
ABLE TO GET ITILL CARRY YOU TO
>> Eddie: THEY SPOKE WILL GET
.
THERE HAVE BEEN OPPORTUNITIES
FOR BOTH TEAMS.
>> Pat: LOOKING
THE PUCK FORTUNATELY OF DAVE
MANSON.
AND THAT IS SAVED BY DOSTAL.
WITH TOEWS SET UP BYTALKED
ABOUT THIS OVER THE YEARS.
IT IS NOT HARD TO BE
THERE IS A GREAT YOUNG START
TALKING ABOUT THE IMPACT
PATRICK KANENE
ANOTHER SAVE. S,
IT HITS THE GOALPOAST.
HERE IS GUSTAFSSON  JUST OUT OF
THE BOX.
HE LEAVES IT ERIK GUSTAFSSON JUS
OUT OF THE PEN
>>AVE HAD 26 GOALS IN THEIR
LAST 11, INCLUDING THREE LAST
NIGHT   LUKAS REICHEL WITH AN
UNBELIEVABLELOT OF
CHATTER.
>> LOVE THOSE
AFTERNOON HOCKEY
HAWKS.
>> Pat:
KANE EXTENDS HIS POINT STREAK
TO SEVEN IN A ROW AND THE
THEY NEARLY MISS TYING THE GAME
SHORTHANDED.ddie:  GRANT HITCK.
IT IS TURNED BACK.FRIEND
OF YOURS?
>> Eddie: WHEN THE GAME IS NOT
GOING ON AND THE LEAGUE, THE DU
TAKE THIS ONE.
RAKELL
KANER HAD NOT SCOREDED